jamais j'aurais cru qu'on en serait
arrivé
[Musique]
làion messieurs bonsoir et bienvenue au
championnat
de on était dans la rue on s'entraîit
dans le métro et maintenant on est au
théâtre au Théâtre du Chatel c'est
énorme c'est
historique
[Applaudissements]
de nouvelles danscez bien le
SMUR r tout a commencé dans les band
français en 8283 break dancing
breon
breakers vous allez pouvoir constater
qu'il s'entraîne très très
sérieusement
[Musique]
lâche pas lâche pas lâche pas là vous
êtes historiquement la la première
équipe de France officielle des B il a
des big girl en France il y en a plein
il y en a la blinde et ce qui en sort là
sur cette saison c'est vous ça veut dire
c'est c'est une petite poignée de B Boy
et big girl de tous les B Boy et big
girl qui a en France et dans cette
petite poignée là au GI maximum il y
aura deux B boy de B girl ceux qui
étaient là l'année dernière vous pouvez
regarder autour de vous il y en a ils
sont plus là ils étaient là pendant un
an et ben là en 2022 ils sont plus là il
y en a qui étaient pas là l'année
dernière et ils sont là et ils sont déjà
en liste senior vous pouvez rentrer dans
les listes vous pouvez sortir des listes
dans les listes vous pouvez passer de
Senior relève espoir collectif national
et tout ça ça va se jouer au niveau des
résultats et au niveau de votre
implication VO la faire courte et simple
on a 2 3 minutes d'accord alors
placez-vous ici s'il vous plaît
placez-vous ici s'il vous
plaît par contre Sam casse les
claquettes la photo ah
moi j'ai froid venez on fait des trucs
comme
ça regardez-moi arrêtez de me
[Musique]
toucher je sérieux je fais sourire je
fais quoi fa un petit sourire pour pas
besoin de tailler une bavette non plus
tu sais frérot des Cres de nez ouais
vas-y ouais désolé hein
[__] tourne ta caméra on appelle ça le
mouchoir du bled on a entendu le bruit
plusurs P ça on commence à changer
mainant on fait des photos officielles
droite parce que les baby boy avant tu
sais on avait une maladie tu sais les
pauses tu fais des photos de famille de
mariage tu tu es le seul sur la photo
comme ça tu vois tout le monde est droit
machin et to tu es là tellement tu as
l'habitude de faire des photos tout le
temps en mode et là on en mode sportif
on fait des Paes de footballeur
là voil
voilà c'est ça qu'on veut c'est ça qu'on
aime bien sûr c'est historique tout ce
qu'on est en train de vivre c'est
historique que ça soit le break qui
rentre aux Jeux Olympiques c'est
historique le fait qu'on soit l'INP
c'est historique le fait que il y ait
une équipe de France c'est historique le
fait qu'il y a un staff équipe de France
c'est
historique vous êtes beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup
beaucoup c'est le plan c'est quoi c'est
tout c'est entier ok non savoir je pas
des PA tuis avait rien à l'époque
c'était vraiment la merde il y avait
rien il y avait
[Musique]
rien on a appris à danser sur des carrés
béton dans des allées vraiment à
l'arrache quoi pensera jamais que voilà
on sera arrivé à là quoi c'est
gigantesque comparé à nous un bout de
carton tu vois ce que je veux
dire
attends sinon on va voir la on va voir
la bidoche non comme ça Salim dans le
break tout le monde le connaît il est
pas dans le politiquement correct ou
quoi que ce soit c'est tout ce qu'il
pense dans sa tête il le dit direct ok
Abdel tu peux avancer un tout petit peu
vers Sélim t'inquiète sur
alors t'inquiète sur la photo c'est
moins chelou que dans la vraie vie tu
pe il est connu aussi pour ses coups de
gueule sur les réseaux
sociaux ça va mir et c'est pour ça que
moi j'ai voulu directement l'associer
dans ce staff là parce que il apporte un
côté bonne humeur un côté rentre dedans
et Salim comme il a été dans le break et
ben il est c'est le même dans l'équipe
de France ça va je suis un beau gosse
quand même comme le trou c'est ça ma ce
qui est bien sur les photo il peut il
remet un peu de de cheveux sur les
photos on voit pas le trou qu'on a au
Jeux Olympiques en 2024 c'est encore
plus historique et là on a le premier
championnat du monde qui vient en France
tu vois châelet donc avant on dansait à
la place carré maintenant c'est dans le
dans le théâtre tu vois et puis le
premier celui qui gagnera sera le
premier champion du monde officiel en
contre un point barre ça va être une
dinguerie vas-y tranquille tac
[Musique]
tac châteler là le sous-sol c'est un
lieu mythique en France
historique quand je parle de rentrer
dans un cercle et claquer des genoux
Châtelet je peux dire que il y en avait
tous les jours des gens qui claquaient
des genoux tu venais même de province
pour y aller là-bas quoi tu vois tu
prenais le train juste pour aller à
châelal et il y a des gens qui venaient
à Châtel qui s'assayaient qui
regardaient et qui dans pas parce qu'il
avaient peur donc voilà c'était le spot
de passer de Châtelet Léal à au T du
Châtelet tu vois avec toutes ces dorures
ces trucs machin tu
vois au Théâtre du châelet tu vois ce
que je veux dire c'est a un côté voilà
donc je trouve que c'est c'est bien
j'aime bien le j'aime bien ce côtél là
tu vois on vient de là-bas mais on est
là tu vois Martin ouais ça te m là tu
sais [__] tes baskets onit des baskets
de Cotor REP quoi tu sais ouais ils
m'ont donné des choses ler
[Musique]
je te présente ou tu me présentes moi
comme vas-y alors lui c'est Kin Mario
lui c'est Martin il a 19 ans il a 17 ans
il danse depuis 10 ans il danse depuis
10 ans aussi voilà et on s'est connu lui
devait avoir à peu près ouais c'est ça 7
ans et moi je devais avoir 9 9 ans
bientôt 10 ans et on était tout petit
tout petit et lui il était d'unkerer moi
j'étais de calis donc ça voulait dire on
se rencontrait tout le temps et celui
qui allait en finale contre moi à chaque
fois c'était
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
lui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sauf qu'on se parlait pas parce que on
s'aimait pas on était Rivau et c'est au
fur et à mesure des battles qu'on a
commencé à bien se connaître et
maintenant on est tout le
temps c'est tout toi tuas un calésien
oubl ou je un
viking dans les pays
nordiques part il avait un d'un côté un
de l'autre puis très jeunes ils ont été
associés l'un à l'autre et puis voilà
après ils sont pas lassés même ils sont
pas de la même ville bah ils prenaient
le train pour se rejoindre l'un et
l'autre machin il ESS de s'entraîner
régulièrement Martin c'est un mec super
attachant voilà on voit qu'il a la dalle
bon après il faut toujours être derrière
eux pour les hein parce que c'est comme
même moi à l'époque he on a T et ça
c'est même pour toi on a tous besoin de
quelqu'un qui nous réveille le matin qui
nous booste un peu en vrai tu vois dans
la vie pour arrêter de fumer pour faire
du sport pour maigrir je parle dans les
gens Gén et ben pour dans la danse bah
c'est ça tu on a besoin de mecs qui
viennent qui te c'est ce qu'on essaie de
faire un peu avec eux parce que voilà
c'est l'âge ou tu vois pour pas qu'il
aillent dans les méandres de de la
jeunesse et qu'ils se perdent dans dans
des délires tu
vois quand on danse on se sent livre en
vrai parce qu'on pense à rien en fait on
écoute notre corps ouis c'est ça c'est
un peu comme un c'est un peu comme un
rappeur qui a besoin d'écrire un texte
pour dire quelque chose bah nous on a
besoin de danser
pour sentir bien sentir bien dans notre
peau je pense que c'est
ça encore encore
[Musique]
encore PL au
Plag c'est là que j'ai grandi c'est là
que toute ma famille àhabite il y a rien
blerio il y a que dalle grander à blerio
c'est pas facile genre il y a rien à
faire on a un stade de foot et c'est
tout rien d'autre une bibliothèque mais
bon j'allais faire quoi la bibliothèque
moi moi mes parents mes deux parents ils
sont de blerio mes grands parents ils
sont de Blerot donc je pense qu'en fait
j'ai que du sang que du sang bleroain
dans les veines qui coulent
[Musique]
ouais alors moi j'ai arrêté l'école
ouais c'est vrai bon après j'ai eu mon
bac toute ma terminale déjà que j'y
allais pas là en plus on m'a confiné bah
ça y est c'était fini l'école en fait
sert à rien pour moins j'envoyais pas
l'utilité j'ai pas besoin de savoir
faire des mats pour tourner sur la tête
pas besoin d'être bon en
philo ça ça doit être les débuts non et
les début je passais déjà dans les
journaux hein ouais mais il a tout le
monde qui a tout gardé je crois la belle
médaille des JJ à buenoser alors ça
c'est quand j'ai été aux Jeux Olympiques
de la Jeunesse c'était la première fois
qu'il y avait le break dans un événement
olympique et j'ai fait médaille d'argent
grâce à Abdel beaucoup grâce à
Abdel les jog c'était la folie hein
c'est la première fois que je voyais
Martha comme ça aussi à limite pleurer
me prendre dans ses bras les parents
dans le
public hyper ému il pleurait à chaque
fois chaque Battle il pleurait quart de
finale pleurait demi-finale pleurait
même quand je gagnais il pleurait ah bah
là le fait d'aller à buenosire j'avais
jamais pris l'avion hein une semaine
avant j'en étais malade j'en pleurais
tellement j'avais peur de prendre
l'avion et puis quand on nous a annoncé
que on nous payait le billet que la
ville de calé nous payer le billet ben
j' a pas faut que j'y aille tant pis
hein mais j'étais pas bien j'ai eu peur
qu'est-ce que j'ai eu peur puis bah je
regrette pas en fait de l'avoir pris he
c'était ma seule fois que j'ai pris
l'avion en
fait c'est incroyable bon ça tu B en
vrai moi je me dis que c'est rien parce
que je me dis je vais faire ça toute ma
vie en fait donc on va pas s'arrêter
maintenant mais ouais ça ça tue bah
surtout dans quand quand ma mère elle
parle en bien de moi et tout c'est cool
puis plein de monde qui me demande après
lui même au travail partout où on va en
fait partout où je vais en fait il y a
des je vais chez une esthéticienne de
blairio elle le connait pas alors et
Martin ça donne quoi enfin partout chez
le coiffeur partout partout partout le
fait que lui il est réussi à à donner
toutes ces émotions là à la France
entière j'ai trouvé ça extraordinaire et
ça fait partie de l'histoire aussi
Sacha
[Musique]
Martin c'est c'est un petit garçon qui
est
dur dur comme faire il a un tempérament
c'est ce qu'il veut c'est ce qu'il veut
mais par contre s'il a pas envie il a
pas envie quand je lui dis qu'il faut
qu'il travaille il me dit moi je veux
pas faire comme toi je vais pas me lever
à 5h euh pour aller faire des
ménage je pense qu'il va réussir j'y
crois
ah ma mère ma mère c'est ma femme ah ma
mère c'est ma femme m mon même mon père
c'est ma femme c'est mes deux femmes je
suis amoureux d'eux pour de vrai c'est
mes amours à fond ils sont tout le temps
là peu importe que ça aille que ça aille
pas ils sont là ça me décevrait de
de l'avir déçu en vrai je serais déçu de
la décevoir j'aimerais bien que mes
parents so so calme comme moi pens plus
à rien leur travail et juste il veulent
ils viennent voir leur fils Brier j'ai
envie que soit ça la vie de mes parents
plus rien faire et voir leur fils danser
c'est
[Musique]
tout si je pouvais moi prendre des
salaires de fou et les faire arrêter
leur travail là allez hop au revoir les
les tafes de de fou vraiment ça c'est le
rêve je vois de la fumée sortir des
épaules de Martin c'est que tout va
[Musique]
bien on y va
allez allez il faut tenir faut tenir
faut tenir
alle Marl enchaîne enchaîne voilà mets
de l'intensité
[Musique]
super je m'appelle Danan j'ai grandi en
guyan je suis arrivé en métropole à peu
près à mes 19 ans Patrice de guyan le
tour de guyan c'est maintenant il est en
tête de Ploton que fait-il il lâche les
bras dét total détente et norm c'est son
assistante qui ramène de
l'eau
ce rire de sorcière on dirait une
sorcière de guyan ça pr
ends celle de moi mais d'accord vas-y
alorsasy pour Facebook tu
connais première bataille pour moi le
climat j'arrive en fin novembre il fait
8°gr à Paris oh j'en pouvais plus
j'avais envie de reprendre l'avion et
repartir en guyan
[Musique]
il y avait un endroit qui s'appelle la
défense c'est là tous les dimanches il y
avait des battles underground nous on
attendait que
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça é à la défense en en allait vers les
les centres commerciaux et en fait à
partir de 18h les magasins fermaient et
il commenç à avoir des Bibo qui commenc
à arriv avec leur Mipro avec leur leurs
petites enceintes ils posaient le sac
ils s'habillaient hop ça s'entraînait ça
[Musique]
s'entraînait et VO c'était chaque groupe
de chaque département du 81 du 95 du du
91 du
80 c'était vraiment moi je suis arrivé
comme ça je voyais c'était une ambiance
un peu chacun dans son dans son
[Applaudissements]
groupe il y avait pas de sécurité il y
avait pas de de choses comme ça en fait
on vait juste pour la danse
on aurait dû prendre le déambulateur
alors tu es fou
toi tu fais jamais le con toi tu fais
jamais le con ouais je dis encore des
bêtises ça fait je un peu de temps en
temps quoi de temps en temps c'est un
petit peu tous les jours quand
même vois je vous avais pas dit mais je
fais je fais de la
danse du Hipop je sais pas si ça vous
dit quelque chose non c'est
on va dire du rap sur la tête ouais oui
ouis ouis ou j'en ai déjà vu donc ben
moi j'en fais en fait ah bon
oui on fait maintenant à peu près 18 ans
et ben il a des championnats du monde là
h et je participe je représente la
France petit stress mais vraiment petit
et puis beaucoup
d'entraînement comment ça va FR ou ça va
bah
oui
tienne à la
vôre on Savit pascoup nous en fait c'est
vrai en fait il nous a toujours caché
qu'il était ouais c'est vrai je ou ouai
il y a pas il y a quelques semaines
maintenant que tu nous as expliqué dit
voilà donc nous on a pris comme un Dani
en fait c'est un super Dani c'est
quelqu'un parce que c'est quelqu'un de
très vrai dans la vie comme dans le
travail et du coup en fait il est c'est
non mais c'est vrai c'est un passionné
dans tout ce qu'il fait il reste
vraiment il est très très humble
vraiment vraiment oua il donne c'est
quelqu'un qui donne vachement donc ou il
est vrai ouais arrêtez
[Applaudissements]
vous cou tu vas
[Musique]
oui bonjour bonjour ah bah sans le bre
on se sera jamais rencontré ça c'est sûr
on s'est connu dans les
battles on s'est
connu
2000 12 oui 12 c'est ça moi j'ai lui ai
toujours dit il le sait je suis pas sa
Fan loin de
[Musique]
là j'ai ma vision la danse parce que
j'ai mon parcours aussi qui n'est pas le
même que le sien et je lui fais part en
général de mes remarques après bonne pas
bonne il en fait ce qu'il
[Musique]
veut bonne
journée mais il sait ce qu'il veut moi
c'est ce qui me plaît chez lui c'est que
il a tête dur comme
[Musique]
moi et moi aussi j'ai envie d'avoir ma
photo à l'INP avec à côté de Teddy Riner
ou David Douillet et ça c'est c'est
c'est une reconnaissance c'est une
reconnaissance commencer dans dans la
rue et avoir une SA sa sa photo dans un
grand une grande structure comme ça que
demander de mieux c'est c'est c'est
carrément euh c'est carrément super pas
mal ce ce
concept allez allonge dan un peu
derrière là te ferme pas comme ça ouais
ouais super ça r ça ok vite ça tourne 15
secondes on se met en place et ça
enchaîne quand j'arrive à l'inep ben
déjà c'est moi le plus vieux Ctait moi
le plus âgé en terme de d'expérience et
en âge bah j'étais un peu j'étais un peu
un peu dégoûté parce que je a que des
jeunes mais après des jeunes qui sont
fort et qui on envie d'en
[Musique]
découdre le regard qui Nar celui qui met
les boules c'est qui fait perdre le
contrôle le regard méchant il y a encore
un peu de travail à faire mais il va
[Musique]
arriver
le break c'est un monde assez masculin
quand j'ai commencé mes premières
compétitions c'était contre des garçons
mon entraîneur il appeler ça le vaccin
c'està-dire que si tu as pas peur d'eux
aujourd'hui tu auras plus peur de
personne et et justement ça a été le le
meilleur entraînement pour
moi j'aime le fait qu'il y ait plus de
garçons au final parce que il nous
traite vraiment à égal donc on est
obligé de se pousser aussi fort que si
eux se jettent du coup toi tu vas tu vas
être entraîné dans ce mouvement et tu
vas essayer de te jeter et essayer des
mouvements que tu aurais pas voulu
[Musique]
faire
non on au bien fort la Tom AV3 12
[Applaudissements]
ans délibération du
jury
two parce que mon nom dérive en beaucoup
trop de surnoms c'est Carlos Carlo ou
Carl des fois mais c'est tellement
devenu habituel que des fois je suis à
l'entraînement et moi-même pour me
bouger dans ma tête je me dis allez Carl
ou mais allez Carl mais les Carlos
c'était parce
que tu étais forte tu faisais des choses
des garçon et son entraîneur pour la
booster lui disait Carlos parce que
Carlos parce qu'elle avait fait déjà les
les petit peu de muscles et après
faisait s'entraîner à faire toujours les
choses comme les garçons donc elle avait
une force une force brute on
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
disait
[Musique]
je viens de Cuba un Cuban qui ne sait
pas danser c'est grave c'est vraiment
c'est très honteux de ne pas savoir
danser ne fais pas
sérieux je me souviens qu'il y a 2 ans
on est allé en bateau Cuba et elle a vu
les danseurs cubin elle m'a dit maman je
sais pourquoi il est
dans comme ça parce que c'est il y a
quelque chose qui est dedans qui est
dans les tripes qui ressort quand elle
danse elle ne peut plus
s'arrêter Carlota c'est une fille qui
danse avec de la technique comme les
garçons là elle est grande elle a une
prestance et tu dis boum elle est sur le
coude tac tac tu dis ah ouais quand même
ça je m'y attendais pas après dans sa
manière d'être attachante dans sa danse
c'est une nouvelle Carlotta c'est plus
la petite Carlotta qui est hyper
dynamique et qui fait de la technique
simplement c'est une Carlotta qui une
big girl maintenant au rang mondial et
il faut juste que maintenant elle fasse
des battles et des battles à
[Musique]
l'international c'est à partir de
maintenant que ça va
commencer
p de
Bou contrôle mentalôle mental contrôle
mental préparation mentale force force
comme ça et là for un peucordcord tu vas
forcer force mais vraiment faut pas que
tu bouges et tu dis je suis Martin tu
t'affirmes je suis mais force je suis
Martin mais je suis léger moi gros mais
force à fond dis je suis Martin je suis
Martin m force mainant dis je suis je
suis Kin
Mario tu vois pas t viux tu vois la
différence en fait quand tu te F C
exercices là c'est pour te faire
comprendre en gros l'importance de se
parler à soi-même de la langue de
s'affirmer d'être ancré de dire je suis
Kimi je sais moi tu vois et tu vois en
fait le fait juste de dire je suis
Carlotta tu le vis pas parce que tu es
pas Carlotta tu veux pas l'intérieur de
toi donc c'est pas la même énergie c'est
pas la même tu vois alors quand tu dis
je suis Marlon tu es ancré c'est pour ça
que j'arrive pas à alors je mets
exactement la même force je porce pas
plus
là
tu tu fais ce que tu veux partir de
là que jeux dire tu fais
top aprs
tu la
direend grandem pour all
grand tu lances ouais c'est déjà mieux
ça largement ce que tu faisais c'est
plus dur et ça c'est plus
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
visuel
vas-y Martin là c'est comme si c'était
un gros battle
[Musique]
international
vas-yom Bou marqueele bien hop Bou c'est
pas grave
continue bom allez respire respire
respire respire et là tu vas chercher
celui où tu touches les pieds hop encore
hop vas-y et va chercher le coup de main
redescends redescends redescends
redescends je suis mort
[Musique]
OK ah faut que j'aille prendre l'air
ouais petit coup de ça m'a serré ça me
sert depuis tout à l'heure tiens tiens
tiens arrête de trouver des excuses non
voilà ferme ta gueule j'ai tout évacué
sa mère vas-y viens rerentre rerentre ah
je suis tout
vide vous avez mangé quoi ce midi
mais j'ai même pas réussi à manger mon
truc
distoi et là là c'est le truc de ce midi
il est pas passé la vie de ma mère non
c'est pas ça là c'est le cardio là ah
ouais mais ouais mais j'ai vomi un truc
ouais j'ai pas vomi du
cardio je le truc de ce midi
ahbrancher le truc là-bas là je vais
courir il va falloir que tu coures et
que tu fasses de la corde et que et pas
que aussi simplement courir et faire de
la corde c'est dans le milieu des
battles c'està-dire là on va faire des
battles c'est pas venir à l'entraînement
ta fait tout ça et tout vraiment faire
des battles à l'entraînement moi quand
je préparé mes un contrat à l'époque je
faisais des un contre 10 à la salle ils
était 10 en face de moi je rentrais
l'autre il rentre je rentrais l'autre il
rentre je rentrais l'autre il rentre là
c'était un contre Sirine vas-y on le
refait si repose-toi un tout petit peu
je mets de la musique on refait contre
DAEM et contre
Sirine bah je doute de tout je doute de
de moi de est-ce que est-ce que c'est
possible est-ce que enfin on est
beaucoup sur Terre on est beaucoup de
danseurs si tu as pas de doute bah bravo
pour toi parce que tu es chaud et moi
des doutes j'en ai ouais des doutes sur
est-ce que ça va marcher est-ce que je
vais trouver ce move est-ce que même des
fois à la salle j'arrive pas à
m'entraîner bah je doute [__] j'arrive
plus à m'entraîner Martin c'est il est
spécial des fois il te casse la tête tu
as envie de lui claquer la tête contre
le mur et il réussit à te refaire en
sorte que tu reviennes vers lui et que
tu l'aides et puis c'est un gros
potentiel potentiel de break potentiel
dans la vie en général et tu as envie de
l'aider bonjour bonjour ça va ça
va les premières fois où on dansait
c'était
ici du balcon on voit tout sur la rue là
tout le terrain bétonné on prenait des
cartons on les mettait au sol et on
s'entraînait il y avait pas de de sol
adapté comme maintenant et du coup on
allait ouais on prenait des cartons on
attendait que le marché devant il
terminé on prenait les gros cartons on
les posait au sol et c'est là les
premières fois on s'est entraînit dehors
mais nous voilà on venait de quartier on
était des bandes de potes on était un
peu là rien faire on avait une table de
pingpong en fer et tu vois maintenant
ils ont des City stades maintenant ils
ont plein de trucs dans les quartiers
non on avait rien à l'époque c'était
vraiment la merde il y avait rien ou il
y avait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
rien
c'est pas pass c'est pas passé la
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
faire c'est le premier battle de break
que j'ai vu en 1995 j'avais 7 ans 6 7
ans et c'est là où j'ai été piqué par le
break
[Applaudissements]
je voyais une énergie des deux côtés
j'ai vu ça j'ai essayé directement dans
le salon de refaire les mêmes mouvements
sans avoir les techniques et depuis j'ai
pas lâché
l'affaire les enfants il fait la danse
ilit même derrière le le bât même sur le
parking le
parkingentrée derrière tout dans c'est
partout tout partout dans tout partout
c'est bon c'est
dur pour faire comme ça c'est pas
facile les parents moi ils écoutaient
pas de musique américaine à la maison
c'était beaucoup de la musique arabe
marocaine ils sont d'origine marocaine
mes parents donc du coup à la radio
j'entendais pas cette musique là aussi
non plus et ça a été un
choc j'avais l'impression de rentrer
dans le monde
parallèle moi je sors de chez moi et je
me retrouve dans un truc de 4 m sur 4
un P Bou dans une cage l'autre qui vend
des surv laoste l'autre qui est là en
train de dire j'ai la dernière cassette
je l' enregistr à la radio je sais pas
quoi le
[Musique]
son grandres dis pas ça pas quand je
arriv break que tu veux ah [__]
j'arrive pas quand tu es un B boy tu
apprends des choses et quand tu arrives
à les faire tu tu as l'impression d'être
un Avengers fait du bruit pour l' que
l'appelle c'est le premier battle que je
fais ici à grande sainte les gens ils
entendaient parler de 59 crew mais ils
avaient jamais vu vraiment et puis voilà
ils ont vu aujourd'hui et ce qui est
bien c'est que 59 CR qui a gagné
phénoménal héroï les superlatifs ne
manquent pas pour célébrer le triomhe
d'Abdel samedi au B boy
[Applaudissements]
France on se croisait oh les gars salut
ça va allez on se metett à l'Opéra et on
se faisait genre des petits défis entre
nous quoi et sauf qu'après onit on
pouvait pas s'implanter vraiment là-bas
en fait et genre on a fait les on était
des mecs de de quartier à C l'époque on
éit un peu CIRA tu vois donc all puis
bah il voulait pas qu'on danse donc
quand Ctait les sécurités bah on les
remballait après des fois c'était les
flics donc des fois et des fois bah ça a
mal tourné ouais parce qu'on on se
laissait pas faire on leur dis mais j'en
fait rien de mal aller arrêter des gens
qui font des qui se battent en ville ou
qui font des des gens il font agresser
non on tourne sur la tête qu'est- vous
nous casser la tête en gros qu- n faire
mal à la
tête on a fait des gardes à vu on a fait
des ah oui je fait des gardes à vu pour
le breakd bon pas que pour mais beaucoup
pour le breakd ça c'est toujours
chamaillé mais on est jamais allé
jusqu'au c'est ça cour devant ça
s'attrape ça se tire les t-shirts dans
pendant le battle tu vois ça attends tu
verras puis à la fin on se parle on se
connait tous depuis 20 ans 30 ans tu
vois donc donc il y a jamais vraiment de
bagarre quoi tu vois eu de trois gifes
de trois coupins de tris qui sont partis
des fois mais c'était mignon
[Musique]
quoi il est où fils de [__]
allô Martin ouais c'est Abdel dis-moi tu
peux venir aujourd'hui à la salle avec
tes parents je dois leur parler vas-y à
tout à l'heure
[Musique]
peace il y a des choses à revoir
concernant Matthéo et Martin c'est que
ils ont été enlevés des listquipe de
France mais ils sont sortis des listes
c'est pas forcément par rapport à leur
niveau c'est par rapport à tout de
manière
générale vous êtes pas à l'école vous
travaillez pas là maintenant ça j'ai
plus besoin d'être derrière vous moi à
100 % vous avez plus 11 ans et 13 ans
vous avez pratiquement 19 ans et 17 ans
ça veut dire que là c'est à vous de de
vous entraîner créer une énergie vous
booster tout c'est d'avoir la motivation
il faut venir c'est ça la [__] la [__]
ouais Martin
entre covid et tout machin plus de
Battle plus de truc on a perdu la
motivation un peu avant il y avait des
battles tous les weekends maintenant il
y en a un tous les 3 mois et normalement
ça ça devrait faire un électrochoc pour
dire bon ben on a le niveau on a le
talent on va s'entraîner à fond et on va
revenir et en plus de ça ceux qui sont
dedans on va les défoncer c'est ça qu'il
faut se dire concrètement Martin et le
permis aussi bah alors ça c'est c'est
compliqué par en plus
tout fait TR j'ai j'ai fait des séries
il fait une semaine et puis là ça y est
tu es malade une semaine après non une
semaine à fond et après j'ai fait des
petits jours de temps en temps machin
mais en vrai le code et le permis tu
l'as tu as plus à te casser la tête pour
venir à la salle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
hein coco ouais ouais ouais encore
encore ouais ouais oua ouais ouais oua
ouais
ouis par contre je veux pas de
commentair je veux pas que tu me donnes
des trucs tu vas me dire des trucs fa
non je regarde avec toi c'est toi
pose-moi pas de question on verra bien
j'appuie à fond sur le frein réponse a
je débraye rép tu l'as eu la fois
dernière tu t'étais trompé
ça souviens oui tu l'avais eu moi je
pense appu à fond sur le frein l'aide au
freinage c'est qu'il faut appuyer non
faut débrayer non je sais pas c'est toi
Martin tu peux pas lire un panneau à 100
m si toi
non quand même
[Musique]
26 le demi-tour est pas mal le demi-tour
du début pas pas mal le demi-tour que tu
fais au début est pas mal ça fait juste
un petit c'est
freestyle il te faut des trucs comme ça
toute façon il faut que tu montes le
toucher allez à loup c'est pas
grave d'accord c'est là où tu dois
forcer dès que tu vois qu'il y a un
loupé il faut que tu dises attends faut
qu'ils oublient mon loup je je monte à
l'intensité lâche pas lâche pas lâche
pas allez allez
allez
voil qu'est-ce qu' va
pas faut que tu forces le truc même si
c'est que de l'écriture même si c'est
pas les M parfait mais fait de A à Z je
me sens
lourd mais même si tu te sens lourd fais
ton passage jusqu'au bout même s'il est
moche ton passage fais-le jusqu'au bout
prends pas le pli de stopper comme
ça c'est
compliqué tu dans la tête
ouais il sent lourd après c'est vrai qu'
les 3 jours de boulot ça je pense qu'il
est fatigé
puis il a enchaîné pas mal de semaines
entre l'INP tout ça les
allers-retours je pense que le corps est
fatigué
mais après c'est la tête qui doit
prendre le relaisin mais bon tu pas dans
sa
[Musique]
tête normalement il devrait pas être là
il devrait pas être là par rapport à son
âge par
rapport il y a il y a quand même
beaucoup de jeunes entre entre voilà 18
et 25 ans ENF c'est là normalement où
quand même on brille et on est au
maximum n Il a la trentaine il va me
dire il est pas vieux mais bon il a
quand même la trentaine passé mais je
suis contente voilà qu' il bouscule un
peu les côes on se dit pourquoi il est
encore là donc non moi je trouve ça
génial et en fait il est encore là et il
est encore là et il va être encore là un
petit moment il va déranger encore un
moment
voilà
alors tu es obligé de la
refaire en sachant que je fais que 1
M70 il faut que j'arrive à donné ah ben
il faut que faut que je montre du
caractère
[Musique]
ok ok rapprochez-vous rapprochez-vous
écoutez bien rapprochez-vous tout le
monde aujourd'hui on va désigner celui
et celle qui va représenter la France au
championnat du monde il y aura 2 jours
de sélection et à l'arrivée on saura qui
ira au théâtre du Châtelet dans un mois
c'est clair pour tout le
monde ça fait des semaines que je les
observe qu'on travaille tous ensemble
chacun donne tout sur les deux jours de
[Musique]
rassemblement Carlotta quand elle se
lance je vois qu'elle est dans son m
elle s'applique elle est sérieuse elle
sait ce qu'elle fait elle est vraiment
très propre dans ses mouvements c'est la
bonne élève elle se qualifie et
[Musique]
facilement et là tu Dan qui arrive je
vois qu'il est déterminé plus que jamais
il a la rage il se dit l'occasion est
trop belle il faut surtout pas que je la
rate et lui aussi il se
qualifie
l'objectif c'est de m'amuser mais gagner
la médaille d'or je veux qu'elle reste
en
France
franchement pour moi c'est carré tu vois
tu es musical tu envoies du la technique
tu as les passes en fait moi j'ai j'ai
peur de pas donner assez d'infos en fait
tu es fou tu en tu as beaucoup d'infos
déjà tu es rapide de ouf dans tes passes
et tout tu es rapide donc il faut voir
tes variantes et tout ça faut les capter
tu vois tu envoies de la technique c'est
beaucoup d'infos franchement tu en fais
moins et tu mets encore plus de présence
tu mets plus d'énergie tout ça ça y est
rigole pas
[Musique]
toi c'est ce qui est compliqué c'est
montrer exemple ement ça fait 18 ans que
je danse montrer 18 ans de danse en 30
secondes vas-y
[Musique]
rentre un cont ça va très très vite ça
dure environ les 2 minutes minutes 35
secondes quelque chose comme ça tu
ressens l'énergie qu'il y a tout autour
de toi tout se passe c'est à l'intérieur
du cercle et tout le public est autour
ouais les premières fois c'est un petit
peu impressionnant de voir le mec le mec
en face de toi en fait c'est vraiment on
dirait vraiment un combat sauf qu'on va
SAF qu'on va danser il a des battles
j'ai pleuré quand tu perds j'ai pleuré
de perdre moi aussi j'ai pas pleuré
avant de le faire genre pas pleurer de
stress tu connais quand tu perds contre
quelqu'un tu as pas envie de perdre tu
pleur quand tu es
petit c'est beaucoup de rapport humain
homme à homme c'est
torse contre torse il y a beaucoup de ça
en fait donc c'est c'est une bagarre en
[Musique]
gros limite un combat UFC mais ça se
touche pas en fait tout
simplement breaker on est vachement tu
regardes bien on est on réfléchit
beaucoup sur le moment je sais pas si tu
remarques bien dans les battles les mecs
on est là on fait on réfléchit pas mais
en fait on est plein de ok tac tac ok tu
vois le mec ouis ça c'est nul ah mais en
fait tu es en train de charer le mec
mais dans ta tête tu es en train de te
dire bon ok il a fait ça moi je vais lui
oh je vais lui rentrer smoth dans sa
tête ah ouais ah non ça je vais oh il a
pris le point là put faut que je fasse
un truc tu vois et après tu vas en
fait en compétition il y a plus d'amis
en compétition il y a plus de copains
c'est toi contte lui il y a plus le
quartier il y a plus la ville il y a
plus la région il y a plus le groupe il
y a plus la France il a rien c'est c'est
une personne lambda en face de toi et en
break il faut la piétiner
th des châelet à quelques heures
du de la
bataille des parfa bon
ici Carlot on est en direct direct
dis-moi ah non ouais ça va oui ça va oui
sà posé la question je me sens bien là
je fais ma petite récupe sur les volet
et j'ai hâte de danser de
danser ça va être très très chaud ça va
être très très
chaud
là on est sur 200 danseurs la crème de
la crème mondiale qui représente 60 pays
au Chatel il va avoir une sale journée
ça ve dire ceux qui vont aller jusqu'en
finale dans les derniers carrés il v
avoir une bonne journée de bataille je
pense tu parce que entre chauffer
refroidir redanser refroidir passer le
prier tour le deème le
[Musique]
machin on estette fin nation fait du
bruit
[Musique]
pour
là faut que tu bombardes de ouf là c'est
de passag je me dis fa les deuxutr je
connais pas donc je me dis je pars quand
même avec si pass si toi tu te dis tu le
connais quand même et ben avec lui ce
que tu sais et garde les autres passages
en fait il en prennent un seul ou deux
ils en prennent qu' le meilleur de la
poli ah justement j'ai pas j'ai pas j'ai
pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bombarde bonne chance mon s tu as
intérêt à tout [__] sinon quand tu
rentres tu auras desfessés
[Musique]
ok c'est le premier battle pour Dan il
va enchaîner toute la matinée dans sa
poule il a tro adversaires il doit
terminer premier pour se qualifier et
arriver au phase finale et là ça démarre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bien bien bien bien
[Musique]
magnifque
pour Carlotta pas de chance elle tombe
d'entrée contre l'une des meilleures au
monde la russe elle se fait éliminer
direct et elle passe pas le premier
tour
ça franchement ça méritait le
franchement
voil ok a le nom je
[Musique]
sais c'est bien c'est bien c'est
bien dan lui il continue de voler il
marche sur l'eau c'est un lion en cage
il gagne tous ses battles il est à fond
et il est en super
confiance bien comment tu t'es senti
franchement à l'aise he je sais plus
bien ça c'est fait 3-0
ok tu es dans le son tu kiffes tu
t'amuses tu donnes ce qu'il faut tu es
bien c'est bon deè j'ai même juste là tu
peux te détendre un peu tu es trop Chud
là ça y est c'est y est c'est
bon quelques heures devant toi là ça y
est a Victor à col
[Musique]
moi oh c'est
[Applaudissements]
boniciell
ouver dan c'est un mec il est fu du fin
fond de la Guyenne ouis nous quand on
l'a vu arriver déjà en métropole il
avait cette énergie cette rage de
vaincre il l'avait déjà dès qu'il a mis
un pied à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Paris il est agressif sur le moment il
pique ça veut dire qu'il va pter du
doigt les faiblesses de l'adversaire si
si y a une petite faiblesse qui est
montrée on sait que Dani va rentrer de
dansans c'est comme
ça tu es à la maison là d'accord c'est
chez toi montre à tout le monde qu'on
est à la maison là il vont tous rentrer
à la maison à
c'est juste un obstacle c'est tout
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
OK
allez allez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
encore
VO
VO voil
[Applaudissements]
OK
ça c'est il lu prend le point normal il
lui prend le point
normal le prochain round est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pourzz
[Musique]
allezz
allez voilà voilà allez belle c'est
voilà c'est
bon non non non
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ohud si vous avez
aé 8 meilleur du monde sur cette
sélection il fautandême
préciser il n reste un battle ble
[Musique]
il Danny il a marqué le coup sur le
premier passage et sur les deux passage
qui suivait ils étaient un peu courts et
il aurait dû juste mettre un peu plus de
matière en en plus de ce qu'il a donné
parce que c'est fort quand même ce qu'il
a fait il aurait pu gagner au la main et
Amir stratégiquement il a mis du contenu
de l'originalité un peu plus poussé
peut-être pas hyper explosif et c'est ça
qui a changé la donne un petit peu je
pensais que je l'avais défoncé ah moi
après je suis pas juge mais je te mais
un point quoi je me suis dit le deuxième
passage j'ai chargé le deuxème passage
je me dit je vais regarder ce qu'il va
faire je vais essayer de faire un peu de
truc comme ça j'ai fait j'ai fait je me
suis dit ah je passe mon frère je suis
beau une fois les fils
de tu m'as fait
plaisir on va retourner s'entraîner et
on va revenir encore plus fort il y a
pas de il y a pas de il a pas de
solution on va laisser le choix à
personne on sait ce que c'est maintenant
on sait comment il faut se préparer on
connaît le format de compétition on
connait le niveau des étrangers et
maintenant il y a plus qu'à
travailler
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
allez doucement doucement doucement
doucement et accélère un petit peu en
même
temps la vérité ça passe pas aujourd'hui
tu es sûr que tu as fait si le son
certain par contre je pense qu'il y a
plus de chance que Martin décrocher une
médaille que son permis de conduire je
commence à comprendre un peu là
ouais ah oui tuaccélères pas tu lâches
trop vite
l'embrayage en tout cas j'ai
vrainé ça arrive ça arrive ça va passer
ça va passer tu
[Musique]
esé